ist 24 ist das Jahr
der Entscheidung ein sotterer im
thüringischen Teich wolframsdorf der
greizer-gebietsverband der AFD plant
hier vor für Superwahljahr 2024 Europa
landtags- und Kommunalwahlen in
Thüringen und besonders auch da kommunal
sehen sie ihre Stunde gekommen
bzw so einen Einfluss haben dass man
nicht an vier aftern im Stadtparlament
im vorbei geht das Ziel muss sein
stärkste und bestimmte Kraft zu werden
vielleicht entdeckend die AFD in der
Kommunalpolitik hier in Greiz ist sie
schon zweitstärkste Kraft im Kreistag
und die anderen Parteien müssen damit
umgehen Martina schweinsburg von der CDU
ist hier Land treten seit knapp 30
Jahren ja der AFD Landesverband gilt als
gesichert rechtsextrem der
Verfassungsschutz beobachtet und doch
eine Brandmauer sei und praktikabel
ehrlich gesagt das war von fangen an im
polit-sprech der sicher auf der
Bundesebene und auf der Landesebene
durchzuhalten ist auch gibt es einzelne
in der AFD mit denen man vernünftig
zusammenarbeiten kann warum nicht ich
arbeite mit Menschen und nicht mit
Parteien und damit ist sie nicht allein
in Thüringen dezember 2022
Hildburghausen
hier heben CDU SPD AFD und auch ein
rechtsextremes Bürgerbündnis gemeinsam
die Hände das Ziel Abwahl des linken
Bürgermeisters der Antrag geht durch der
Ärger über die Zusammenarbeit mit der
AFD groß was ist wichtiger sach-themen
durchsetzen oder parteigrundsätze auf
der kommunalen Ebene ist die
parteipolitisierung ohnehin ein bisschen
zu weit vorangeschritten gerade nach dem
ZDF sommer-interview mit Friedrich Merz
kochen die Diskussionen über Brandmauern
und die Löcher darin hoch auch in der
Thüringer Landeshauptstadt
das ist für mich taktisch sehr unklug
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen und wir
haben ja die Diskussion im Fernsehen
verfolgt wie das selbst in seiner
eigenen Partei nicht unbedingt gut
angekommen ist kategorisch nein kann man
nie sagen darf man auch nicht sagen so
hier nach vorne gehen und leider wird zu
viel politisch parteimäßig gemacht was
ich nicht gut finde man kann vermeiden
für Anträge der AFD zu stimmen oder für
andere Projekte der AFD sollte man vor
allem sollten sich die Parteien darüber
unterhalten wie sie das handhaben wollen
und das tun sie vielleicht und da kann
man Mazda dankbar sein für seine ja
unbedachte Äußerung für den Thüringer
CDU-Chef Mario Vogt gilt keine
Zusammenarbeit keine Koalition mit der
AFD aber das ist eine herausfordernde
Situation aber es gehört halt auch mit
dazu dass man nicht ausgrenzt aber sich
klar abgrenzt und gleichzeitig gilt aber
auch wenn jetzt ein Wähler wenn jetzt
ein Bürgermeister von den Freien Wählern
oder von der CDU in Anruf von dem AFD
Landrat bekommt also der dann sagen oh
jetzt klingelt das blaue Telefon ich
nehme jetzt nicht ab das ist doch Lebens
fern man muss sich inhaltlich Absetzen
von einer Partei die in Thüringen längst
flächendeckend präsent ist Sonnenschirm
Klapptisch Prospekte kleiner Aufwand
beim typischen afd-stand aber erhebliche
Wirkung denn so wie hier in Ohrdruf
bespielt die Partei überall die
Marktplätze und das fällt auf weil sie
zum Volk gehen sehen wir eine andere
Partei hier ist sie keine andere Partei
und das das Problem wenn die wollen
natürlich da aber ansonsten ist die AFD
die einzige die eigentlich regelmäßig
alle paar Wochen hier stehen
34% stärkste Kraft im Freistaat so die
Umfragen doch diese Erfolge bringen für
die AFD auch praktische Probleme für
super weil ja denken Sie auch beim
Greizer gebietsverband nach wer
überhaupt geeignet wäre als Kandidat und
ob sie genug Bewerber finden
wenn wir auftreten muss das Hand und Fuß
haben und der lieber in einigen
Positionen niemand als eine Pfeife noch
gibt es keine Listen und keine genauen
Wahltermine für Thüringen aber klar ist
wohl das 2024 nicht nur für die AFD ein
besonders wichtiges war ja wird